outrage after Greece's worst ever train
crash exploded into violence again on
Sunday
among the thousands protested in central
Athens through fire bombs and rocks
police used tear gas
unrest is broken out around the country
since a collision between two trains on
Tuesday 57 people were killed
rail workers have been staging rotating
strikes angry at what they say is under
investment and poor safety
infrastructure
earlier the protesters launched hundreds
of black balloons to commemorate the
Dead
prosecutors have charged a station
Master for allowing the passenger train
onto the same track as an oncoming
freight train but many in the country
blame an under-resourced aging rail
network
[Music]
they should stop looking at the profits
and start looking at the lives of people
our children this must never happen
again we shouldn't be afraid to put our
children on our country's Metro and
trains
despite the continuous warnings of the
workers there was criminal indifference
by those responsible to our requests of
the safety systems and that is what led
to this tragic accident the scale of
this accident has horrified the country
on Sunday the Prime Minister apologized
and said a long delayed remote signaling
system would have made the disaster in
practice impossible
a few kilometers North along the track
people gathered to remember those kills
five days on from this tragedy across
the country the grief and anger remain
raw Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera